this is the Motorola Droid
this is Motorola second Android phone
and it's quite possibly the coolest
piece of hardware they've released since
the Razr so this is running Android auto
it's a great operating system and it's
also on Verizon's network which is
extremely fast they have great 3d
coverage earlier we were surfing the
internet with this guy and it was
bringing up pages faster and cleaner
than the iPhone does I uses the same
sort of technology at the iPhone uses it
reads the electricity in your fingertips
so it's very responsive it doesn't have
any multi-touch so you can't actually
pinch on it but what you can do to zoom
in on something is you can double tap it
it's also got this very cool 5 megapixel
camera on it it takes great pictures
they're noise free it also has a
slide-out QWERTY keypad so when you want
to type out a text message quickly or
maybe get online and type in a URL fast
you got right here and you don't have
any ambiguity that a virtual keypad hath
so the turn-by-turn navigation on the
droid is awesome what it does is that
there's a it comes up with a map like a
Google Street View and then it'll
overlay the instructions on how to get
to your destination over the map so it's
kind of like augmented reality but
better because it's actually useful
they'll be available in November through
Verizon for $200 and a two-year contract
is it worth it absolutely for what we've
seen so far this phone on the awesome
verizon network which is if you've ever
seen a map of it compared to a TTS is
superior in virtually every way totally
worth it